Antoinette a mum of two has incurable
blood cancer
she's been looking for a stem cell donor
for nine years myeloma has
um Ruined My Life
um
I've had to go through chemotherapy
eight different types of chemotherapy
throughout the years
just before the pandemic I gained 13
spinal fractures because the myeloma had
spread to my spine
if someone came forward and I you know
they matched for me
although it wouldn't cure me it would
give me my best chances of survival if I
were to receive a match I could have
another
20 years maybe Plus
people who are black Asian or from an
ethnic minority background have a 37
chance of finding the best possible stem
cell donor match but for people who are
white it's 72 percent and campaigners
want to change this inequality
patients are mostly matched with a donor
from the same ethnicity as themselves
the problem is fewer people come forward
to register as a potential donor from
ethnic minority backgrounds
within our community there's been lots
of myths and fears and taboos about
giving something of yourself
triggered a lot by what's been done
historically to the black race through
hundreds and hundreds of years
especially clinical research so what
we've had to do is educate
um our community to get people to really
appreciate that my ethnicity can be of a
real assistance to someone
after hearing a campaign on the radio to
recruit more donors from ethnic
minorities Natasha joined the UK stem
cell register
15 years later she saves someone's life
I remember getting the call to say that
we think you're a match which was
incredible so I was straight away what
do I need to do next like get me get me
there
we had oh I had the best nurses that I
couldn't have been asked for more they
looked after you they kept you informed
with everything to be honest I'll do it
tomorrow in a heartbeat it was the best
experience
Antoinette continues to wait for her
match but time is running out
Alice Porter Sky News